[Musique]
sans quasi accueille ce matin miguel
laventure bonjour monsieur aventure
bonjour maurizio temps bonjour à tous
nos auditeurs et auditrices conseiller
exécutif en charge des finances et des
orientations budgétaires de la ctm
peut-on considérer miguel laventure que
nous sommes dans un virage en tout cas
dans un tournant dans les relations état
collectivités locales au vu de tout ce
qui s'est dit ces derniers temps on va
par va rappeler le conseil des régions
de france ici chez nous les déclarations
des douars à philippe sur de nouvelles
méthodes de travail
le climat est propice pour une nouvelle
relation mais je pense qu'il faut
prendre l'initiative
aujourd'hui on se rend bien compte que
lily a nécessité de créer un nouveau
dynamisme à un moment où l'état semble
donner quelques signes de au contraire
reprendre la main sur un certain nombre
de sujets alors que je vous le savez
surtout dans nos espaces d'outre-mer il
y a assez naturellement une impatience à
voir en consentent à faire en sorte que
l'initiative la responsabilité puisse
être exercé complètement en ayant
évidemment les moyens vous pouvoir les
mettre en oeuvre
et cela s'est manifesté d'une masse
toute façon assez spectaculaire au
niveau national puisque l'association
des mères l'association des départements
l'association des régions demandent à
l'état un autre type de relation il y a
eu un temps extrêmement fort
effectivement c'était 27 27 septembre
par conséquent il ya la pile un mois
avec les représentants de ces niveaux de
collectivités de toute mon expérience
politique c'est la première fois que je
vois quelque chose d'aussi solennelle
d'aussi regrouper d'aussi unis est me
semble-t-il de 6 déterminer puisque on
dit que probablement l'état va entendre
cela classe et déjà traduit par
l'organisation même angoissant puyo puyo
kwata et l'objectif c'est inévitablement
de faire en sorte que healy et gouaille
et non seulement j'y crois mais je crois
qu'il faut en toute hypothèse en prendre
l'option est opéré de cette manière
décentralisation nouveau chapitre ou
bien simple travaux spécifiques portant
comment dire sur le doit à une certaine
différenciation
bien sûr la différenciation est à
l'ordre du jour mais c'est surtout le
fait de pouvoir exercice est nombre de
responsabilités braver bon très facile
pour moi de je dirais de m'engager je
vais devoir vous savez que c'est l'adn
des forces martiniquaises de progrès ces
deux facteurs d'existence survenant
d'existence 20 ans d'existence et ça
arrive pile à un moment où nous
considérons que oui la décentralisation
c'est probablement la réponse ajusté
quelle évolution dans le discours miguel
laventure autorisé bois lalalala
réponses ajustées à deux nécessités la
première c'est effectivement de faire en
sorte que la situation concrète évolué
pour qu'on ait plus de développement
moins de chômage plus d'implication du
plus grand nombre
et deuxièmement l'impatience elle évoqué
tout à l'heure de pouvoir exercer un
certain nombre de pouvoirs alors
décentralisation signifie que l'on est
dans l'ensemble national que l'on a
choisi d'en faire
l'espace je dirais de conquête mais
également que l'on veut sécuriser
l'ensemble de la démarche parce que
regardent les droits on renforce
légalité et on assure une sécurité
on y arrive tout de suite mais quand
même il n'y a pas une sorte de de solde
de tout compte qu'il faudrait demander
lorsqu'on sait que en sont prétexte de
décentralisation l'état s'y retirer par
exemple sur les aides sociales
on attend toujours le versement de
certaines sommes alors mais on est on
est vraiment sur cette nécessité vous le
lisiez de faire en sorte que chacun
exerce ce qui est son périmètre lorsque
nous prenons les aides les allocations
individuelles de solidarité que vous
évoquiez à l'instant eh bien on constate
que depuis que tout a été mis en oeuvre
il y a eu toujours un décalage entre ce
qui a été servi à l'époque le
département le conseil général et
maintenant la ctm et puissent les moyens
qui sont donnés par l'état
on est à peu près aujourd'hui à quelque
chose comme 250 millions sur
l'historique alors quel crédit accorder
à l'état lorsqu'on parle c'est pour ça
qu'il faut véritablement négocier
discuter non pas être dans l'incantation
et la proclamation mais véritablement
organisé un dialogue de fermeté vous
êtes un vieux guerrier de la politique
martiniquaise hcc qui sera créé est-ce
qu'on a su tirer toutes les leçons du
passé sachant que abel et a dit oui et
puis pendant ce temps nous l'acadie nous
n'avons pas d'autre choix que la
discussion et la négociation nous avons
absolument besoin de rentrer dans cette
voie là parce que nous ne pouvons rien
imposé à l'état et nous le voyons bien
avec cette loi de finances qui est
actuellement en discussion au parlement
avec une étape importante a été franchie
d'adoption par l'assemblée nationale
d'éléments qui sont extrêmement inquiète
a est préoccupant lorsqu'on voit comment
la question de la voiture c'est qu'elle
quel crédit dans tout ça quel crédit
non mais tu ne t il ya de génial de
niveau il ya ce que fait l'état et il y
à ce que réclament les élus qui sont rur
l'émanation et l'expression quotidienne
des attentes de la population ce que
fait l'état aujourd'hui et qui se
traduit par cette loi de finances et qui
est extrêmement inquiétant est
préoccupant c'est précisément de rester
et peut-être même d'aggraver la position
qui consiste à mobiliser les moyens en
sa faveur à sa main dans ces périmètres
jeu prenait l'exemple à l'instant de 7
cet élément que les martiniquais
connaissent bien c'est l'abattement
fiscal oui c'est à dire que les impôts
sur le revenu et bien ils sont ils
bénéficient bénéficier on sait ce père
que vous avez durée d'une diminution qui
pouvait aller jusqu'à un peu plus de
5000 euros et le gouvernement a proposé
qu'on puisse revenir à un bon niveau de
2450 euros ça veut dire que l'état dit
je vais prélever davantage mais si ce
prélèvement doit conduire à ce que non
seulement on en mange de ressources qui
va circuler dans tout le territoire mais
que c'est cette ressource soit entre les
mains de l'état même pas entre les
maîtres ou collectivités martiniquaise a
fait sa musique et les danses et elle
fait danser
non seulement ça mais l'utilisation la
finalité ne sont pas aujourd'hui
définies parce que ce sera entre les
mains de l'état
c'est extrêmement inquiétant vous avez
quelqu'un qui paie l'impôt sauf que sauf
que me jetez moi bien quelqu'un qui paie
l'impôt
si vous lui laissez la possibilité d'en
payer un peu moins
il va l'utiliser là où il est c'est à
dire sur le territoire et ça va se
manifester de toutes sortes de manières
à consommer davantage il va il va
recruter un jardinier il va mettre son
argent dans une entreprise si l'état le
prend et que l'état en plus ne vous dis
pas que il va vous associer à la à
l'utilisation de cet argent n'a commencé
à être non seulement inquiets il est
dans une certitude que un peu le dîner
de cons cette histoire que vous aurez
que vous aurez pas le profit de cet
argent
alors comme ça c'est quand aujourd'hui
c'est dense y est je dirais ce contexte
là qu'est de contexte extrêmement
réducteur en termes de moyens mais
surtout en termes de décisions locales
que nous considérons qu'il faut
absolument se mobiliser et je le dis
très simplement
ça n'est pas un combat politicien mais
nous avons déjà démontré miguel
laventure dans un passé tout près tout
près que l'on formule des choses comme
ça et puis on sursaute quand s'est
repris au pied levé par l'état
l'exemple de l'abattement fiscal
allemand est ce que les élus
martiniquais sauront faire face à cette
nouvelle donne est ce qu'on ne va pas
jouer aux apprentis sorciers et puis
de trois ans dans vous le reprocher vous
avez raison de rappeler que
malheureusement ce que l'état propose là
a pu avoir été proposé par des élus
martiniquais c'était l'ancienne majorité
au conseil régional qu'il avait
formulées dans un document public
officiel lequel ghana parce que c'est
votre responsabilité aujourd'hui comment
être sûr je reformule la question
comment être sûr que les élus
aujourd'hui ne joueront pas les
apprentis sorciers et ne risque pas de
formuler des choses que nous
regretterions par la suite nous sommes
au coeur du sujet je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les martiniquais et les
martiniquais citoyens mais encore plus
leurs représentants élus ont conscience
une conscience grandissante de ce qu' il
y a dans leurs mains
quelque chose dont il faut qu'ils
s'emparent et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous espérons que le temps qui
s'ouvre va être un temps de solidarité
martiniquaise j'espère que enfin si vous
renoncez chaque fois que vous avez c'est
à vous de démontrer en martinique a
récemment alerté le flou comme il aime à
le dire ça veut ça veut signifier que en
ce moment il y a pour l'ensemble des
martiniquais une opportunité peut-être
historique de faire en sorte que sur
cette question de la responsabilité
locale partagés sur cette opportunité je
répète de faire en sorte que tout le
monde puisse mettre d'accord est bien de
dépasser les clivages de dépasser les
intentions de dépasser les eur
envie d'un schéma de la moder sonel vous
savez qu'on a envie de vous croire
sauf que je souhaite que non seulement
on ait envie de me croire mais que l'on
ait envie le du développement de la
martinique parce que c'est à ce prix que
nous y arriverons d'autre les deux
principaux blocs politiques de ce pays
pourrait s'asseoir pour travailler sur
un projet commun je pense qu'il ne faut
exclure personne et par conséquent ne
pas réduire le débat politique à deux
entités je pense qu'il faut au contraire
précisément il c'est fondamental donner
à chaque martiniquais d'échappement
technique et l'espace et la circonstance
de la discussion et de l'implication
je suis convaincu j'entends ça dans la
rue mais j'imagine vous aussi qu'il ya
aujourd'hui un état d'esprit
consiste à dire mon bon et puissiez
cocan c'est important en clamant bon
épicé comme les piscines salles à ce
montant la cola etc avocats des familles
de nos connaissances y nommer les gens
ils ont ils sont exaspérés de voir ce
qui ne fonctionne pas et par conséquent
si nous donnons l'opportunité et c'est
ça qui a été fait la semaine dernière
c'est de dire lançons si pas rien comme
expression les assises les libertés
locales
c'est à dire faisons en sorte qu'ils
puissent y règne en musique une grande
réunion de constitution nous non non
c'est pas un assez gros mais ce bail
concernant non non non plus se faire à
toutes sortes de niveaux y compris
permettait en état de coupable vous
mettez tout mena dans ses côtés ouais
faisons en sorte que les contributions
des martiniquaises et des martiniquais
soit je dirais accueillir cueilli
susciter des assises de l'autre mère
dernièrement mais non mais il faut rien
il faut bien pleurer il faut construire
si nous passons notre vie à dire si
impossible on l'attend et ça n'a pas
marché
chaque fois qu'on a voulu le faire ça
n'a pas abouti et biens de qualité de la
république à plairait aujourd'hui ça
n'est pas mon état d'esprit ça n'est pas
en tout cas ce que le groupe fort soit
inégale de programme et je crois pouvoir
dire que ce n'est pas non plus ce que
aujourd'hui la majorité de la cité m
alors qu'elles aient manqué les écrire
en quel écran quel élu travaillera sur
sur sur ces assises est ce que ce sont
les élus de la 7e compte tenu du poids
de cette collectivité en martinique
est-ce que c'est l'élu d'opposition
d'une des toutes petites martinez
communes de martinique par exemple je
pense que tout le monde est appelé à
être à ce rendez vous de la
responsabilité réfléchi et le peuple
lui-même précisément tout le monde je
viens de dire aux médias nous même et
n'ai pas dit où les élus je pense que
tout le monde à l'eau est vitale
quand même un discrédit de
l'intéressement mais s'il y en avait
mais vous pouvez pas tout démolir en
même temps c'est pas vrai aujourd'hui
des personnes ont choisi des
représentants les élus ils ont la
mission
mais aujourd'hui il y a une population
et je pense que de temps en temps il
faut faire ce double niveau de la
discussion est bien celui de celui qui a
été
de ceux qui ont été mis en place pour
pouvoir s'exprimer au nom de tous mais
également ceux qui sombre dans une
capacité de contribution et et je suis
absolument convaincu mais il s'agit de
le faire de manière solidaire je suis
absolument convaincu que tout les
martiniquais de tous les mardis dès
qu'elles vont jouer ce jeu là
merci miguel laventure conseil exécutif
bonne journée
merci beaucoup
[Musique]